Tory Lanez in jail yeah
I think I was gonna say that because it
started within you put an emphasis on
the end there Tori Tori oh I did
no Tory Lanez in jail as he should be
yeah yeah because you can't shoot black
women no no well protect black women any
woman you can't do whatever you want to
whiteness
just got to jail maybe he's doing an
Alex media he's doing a quick 30. you
know what I mean in the European jail
he's doing a hard time
if you shoot a black woman one time yeah
you do in jail time yeah if you imprison
and maybe a bunch of white women around
the clock and then monetize it yeah and
start your own University yeah if you
start your own University teaching young
men how
white women
allegedly I make money on the internet
yeah all right
okay then you get 30 days then you get
maybe 30 days before we can figure it
out yeah what are they gonna figure it
out it's white women
I mean if it was a black woman you think
he's getting off absolutely you think of
entertain that black woman in there he's
gonna get off
hold on you think for a goddamn second
house which is getting awful are you
talking about it
do you think if Andrew Tate had black
women
in his sex Castle yeah
because about why we have no notices but
he's like I could just go to Slovakia
and I could grab a couple women and
bring them back in and then make some
money and it's like bruh if you said
this about any other color yeah it'd be
a little crazy right yeah you could just
go to Ghana and come back with three
black women no probably not no but but
that's also been done before the
historical precedent for that being
[ __ ] up yeah oh you think white people
have been slaves I'm sure they have they
don't get the same PR you know what I
mean why not probably because they also
[ __ ] media that's what it is
crazy
[Music]
is a powerful thing you can't even shoot
black ones no it's crazy dude you can't
even be a Canadian guy shooting black
women dude isn't that [ __ ] nuts man
do you think he's do you think he's
guilty who Tory Lanez uh I know yeah you
know how do you know welcome to now yes
I will record this today yeah
he's guilty of shooting Megan the
stallion did you listen to the apology
the apology it was apology Tory Lanez
first of all he was not right yes I was
yeah
[Laughter]
I had the closest to what happened yes
[Music]
I'm trying to set him up for a joke
[Laughter]
got it
okay okay where were we we're talking
about uh entertainment yeah and how he
was right about about Tori yeah what did
Andrew say about Tori
[Laughter]
and DJ academics and based on the
information that they were putting out
it looked like Tori was coming Instagram
journalist Miss lettuce the Instagram
journalist that's the only time I've
been Furious a grand wizard bro I've
been promoting him every single week he
got me out here thinking that this black
woman that got shot to life you thought
she was a white woman for a long time no
I didn't no you didn't I didn't do that
a little too far you said you said Oh I
thought Magnus down he was a white woman
no Martin and that's why Tori's gonna
get off
yeah
you called her Megan the show Pony with
an H wow you said that I love white
women I'm trying to free the white women
in Tate's Castle wow respect I'm Mario
[Laughter]
you look like Mario
[Laughter]
and I'm going to Romania and I'm gonna
free the white women from the castle you
were right about Megan stallion yeah
what were you right about that no he
actually told me it seems like the
internet's saying she's gonna be he's
gonna be innocent but I think he's gonna
get found guilty he said that to me and
I said that I think they got into uh
kerfuffle in the car and then I think
Victoria kerfuffle is a funny way to now
he's convicted
it's like altercation altercation who
fought did you think Tori and then Tori
saw that he couldn't beat her so he took
out a gun
that's what they were kerf buffalo about
yeah what yeah
yeah clawsicle what he's saying is they
got no physical altercation yeah and
then Tori realized I can't beat it
because there were pictures of their
body like they all had bruises like they
were in a
heated fight um
[Laughter]
Kelsey was bruised up too from Tori
apparently Tori is beating on her ah
yo it turns out
tour is kind of a piece of [ __ ]
I should have known when he DM me to
come on the Pod and I was like buddy
we're gonna have to talk about what's
going on and then just looked at it
never responded right then in that
moment I should be like hey you might
have shot that one
DMV no son let me go look she also be
having the blue checks in his DMS boy no
does anybody I mean honestly a little
sexy so far so far
oh I DM him my bad come on bro you come
on
[Laughter]
um yeah but he was down
yeah
I go yeah
this is the name currently accused of
shooting him
he goes we gotta do it my bro where you
at I go NYC uh we we would love to
I think you're um I go I think you're
unreal talented at music which is true
that's true I go now your people don't
want us to talk about the stallion
situation
I go we're not a gotcha podcast the goal
is to have fun but we have to at least
acknowledge
[Music]
acknowledge what the horse that you
definitely shot the [ __ ] out of that
you did not say
ing
no response reasonable reasonable
outside of a tour in this one nothing
else but this one I'm with him
for this one yeah for this one a million
percent
I don't know but we have to at least
acknowledge that we're not discussing it
or we seem uh we seem inauthentic and uh
I don't want us to seem inauthentic
obviously but then obviously seeing no
response because he didn't want to talk
about what really happened and he knew
we were going to get to the
[ __ ] truth
brings me right that's the age routine
do you know why you thought he was
comfortable with your [ __ ] teeth you
know why you thought he was innocent do
you remember this why he got Tory Lanez
is innocent we're like you said it on
the Pod and we're getting in jail
eight months ago when all this happened
we go why did he go he's at the
nightclub the next day I was like what
and you were like he's smiling at the
nightclub there's no way he did it just
put out an album he's like no way he's
gonna put out new music
how could you not divide all the
expectations how could you how could you
not have that like just grinding away in
their minds
Al why are you acting like you didn't
think he was innocent killed his wife
and then play golf yeah this is what hey
hey this is honestly this is what
criminals do he got off white woman
hey good point
you don't shoot white women you can
shoot white women shoot to be fair again
you're right he was respectful yeah
you're right that's a lesser crime but
we don't know if he did that we don't
know if he did no he didn't he
technically he's innocent yeah unlike
Tori he's in who's technically guilty
who is technically guilty yes and Bill
Cosby who is technically innocent he was
guilty no he was guilty and then let off
on a technicality yeah so technically
innocent no he's not innocent still
technically not guilty he's not he's not
guilty
so he's back to innocent
I don't know how the math works out but
I think because you're innocence
come on do they have that Romania I
don't think you know Cosby's victims
mostly were white women exactly you can
the shame
the shame in the world today is you can
do almost anything to
him and you will get no justice
whatsoever yeah it is a travesty we
gotta stand up we gotta protest protect
white women yep
white women's lives matter white women's
lives matter yep yes that's facts
you know what I say to that all women's
lives matter
oh
oh that's true no but right now we're
focusing on one woman's life or one
group of women's Lives who seem to be
more affected than the other women's
lives yes what you're saying is true but
we just want to put some focus on the
one you're just saying it as a reaction
I personally just don't see color and I
want to focus on all women I feel like
you're doing to under my
mind no I don't think I am this side
exactly do you know hey hey guys I get
it I get why you do this yeah it's fun
it's a fun position to take
all women's lives matter what you're a
Nazi
you're nice yeah I'm sure or not yeah
you're a Nazi no no you want to do mud
[ __ ] Nazi
and I gotta stay here
you're a Nazi bro that's Nazi [ __ ] that
you were just doing right there we're
trying to save white women